if you are dreaming of an old-fashioned
Christmas then liquor lineup the
sponsors of this segment they have a
cocktail for you
Welcome to our shop I'm Solomon Nick
what do we have for the liquor lineup
today well today we're making a really
easy and elegant cocktail for the
holidays and we are using my favorite
bourbon it's old Forester and we just so
happen to have a really amazing Single
Barrel pick that you can't find anywhere
that's right this store pick you can
find it on our website liquorlineup.com
where we have limited and allocated
bottles whiskey Tequilas Etc all right
so I'm doing two ounces of that lovely
bourbon I'm doing a half ounce of simple
syrup
[Music]
and then I'm doing three dashes of
angostura aromatic bitters
and one dash of orange bitters also from
angostura
we're just going to stir this up
and you can use your ice at home if you
have a big sphere or cube that also
works great as well
[Music]
be found on our app download our app
liquor lineup we deliver daily and we
can deliver these ingredients you can
make this cocktail at home all right
finish it off with the twist
and there you have your festive fashion
[Music]
Nick that's really phenomenal phenomenal
and strong happy holidays cheers
thank you liquor lineup for sponsoring
this segment give them a call at
702-616-0311 for more information you
can also scan that QR code right there
on your screen